we would now like to begin our analysis
of motion and we'll start with one
dimensional motion let's just consider a
person running along a road and so
here's our runner and here's our road
and what we want to do is be able to
describe the position the velocity the
acceleration of this runner in order to
do that we need our first mathematical
tool which is a coordinate system what
is a coordinate system
well the first thing that we want to
choose is an origin we can pick the
origin anywhere we want
that's a degree of freedom so let's
choose a point along our road as our
origin the next thing to do is to choose
an axis well the road is naturally
defining an axis for our problem and so
we'll call this the x axis now along
with that axis we want to divide that up
into some type of units so we might
divide our axis like this and what's
important here is to introduce a
positive coordinate direction and so the
way I'll do that is I'll call this the
plus X and on this side of the origin X
is negative now the third most important
thing is that we're going to talk about
vectors in physics so we want a choice
of unit vector now because it's only one
dimensional motion we only need one unit
vector so what that means is a choice of
unit vector at every point let's just
consider a point here p1 so our unit
vector I'll call it I hat 1 now let's
pick another point here we'll call this
the point p2 and over here we'll choose
a unit vector I had to so every single
point in space has a unit vector now
what's unique about this one dimensional
linear partition coordinate system is
the following these unit vectors have
the same magnitude a unit vector by
definition has magnitude 1
and they're pointing in the same
direction so if two vectors have the
same magnitude and point in the same
direction they're equal so what makes
this coordinate system unique this
Cartesian coordinate system that at
every single point no matter where we
are the unit vectors point in the
positive direction because they have the
same magnitude and direction
all of these unit vectors are equal and
we call that I hat so symbolically we
may draw the a picture and indicate our
unit vector in the positive x-direction
and this is our coordinate system and we
can next begin to describe the position
and the velocity of our object as it's
moving along this x direction